,
WE WERE TELLING HER DURING THE
CAMPAIGN.
LET ME GET A LITTLE AHEAD OF THE
CURVE AGAIN.
BATMAN IS NOT MENTALLY FIT TO BE
PRESIDENT, AND THE PEOPLE AROUND
HIM COVERING ALL OF THIS UP,
THEY ARE THE WORST TYPE OF
ENABLERS BECAUSE THEY ARE
PUTTING THE COUNTRY AT GREATER
RISK, EVEN THE WORLD AT A
GREATER RISK.
HERE WITH REACTION, AUTHOR OF
"HERE'S THE DEAL,"
KELLYANNE CONWAY, NUMBER ONE
"NEW YORK TIMES" BEST SELLER,
AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
JOE CONCHA.
KELLYANNE, LOOK, I POINTED OUT
DURING THE CAMPAIGN, I GOT
CRITICIZED.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYBODY
THAT HAS ANY OUNCE OF
INTELLECTUAL HONESTY CAN ARGUE
WITH THE FACT THAT HE'S JUST NOT
UP FOR THE JOB.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
WILL DEMOCRATS TAKE THE BOLD
STEP AND TELL HIM THAT?
>> HE'S NOT.
WELL, THEY FEAR THAT THAN THE
NEXT PERSON IN LINE FOR THE JOB
ISN'T UP FOR THE JOB EITHER.
HER NAME IS KAMALA HARRIS, AND
SHE DOESN'T DO MUCH BETTER AT
THE TALKING THING AND HE DOES.
>> Sean: I AGREE.
SHE'S NOT UP FOR THE JOB EITHER.
>> STRONGLY SO.
SHE'S NOT.
SO THERE IS THAT FEAR, BY THE
WAY.
YOU KNOW IT IS SO FASCINATING,
ISN'T IT, THAT WHEN THE
DEMOCRATS NOW ARE COMING OUT OF
THE WOODWORK AND SAYING SOMEHOW
A GUY WHO WASN'T TOO OLD 18
MONTHS AGO IS TO ALL NOW, AND
INFIRM, THEY STOP SHORT OF
SAYING GET RID OF HIM NOW, JUST
DON'T RUN AGAIN IN 2024 BECAUSE
THEY DON'T SAY LET'S JUST GET
KAMALA TO STEP IN THERE.
SHE NEITHER, LIKE HIM, SHE ALSO
DOES NOT INSPIRE CONFIDENCE OR
DEMONSTRATE COMPETENCE.
LOOK, THIS IS BINARY.
UNDER DONALD TRUMP, RECORD LOW
POVERTY.
UNDER JOE BIDEN, RECORD LOW
APPROVAL RATINGS.
UNDER DONALD TRUMP, WE HAD THE
HIGHEST ON A PLUMMET IN 50
YEARS.
UNDER JOE BIDEN, HIGHEST
INFLATION, 40 YEARS.
WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT?
WELL, IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT
WAS MORE ABOUT THE INDIVIDUAL
PERSONALITIES OR EVEN
PRESIDENTS, IT WAS ABOUT POLICY.
AND I THINK WE ARE ALL BEING
SEDUCED INTO TALKING TOO MUCH
ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
AS FUN AS IT IS, I THINK WE
SHOULD BE TALKING WITH THE
DEMOCRATS, SEAN.
THE DIFFERENCE WITH 15 SEATS
REPUBLICANS IN THE FALL, THE
ABILITY TO MAKE ALL THE
DEMOCRATS, NOT JUST JOE BIDEN,
OWN AND EAT ALL THESE TERRIBLE
POLICIES PER YOU HAVE THE THESE
POLITICIANS NOW PRETENDING THAT
SHE WAS WORRIED ABOUT INFLATION,
SHE WAS MOURNING THE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE, OH, NO, WHAT CAN WE
DO.
IT REMINDS ME OF THE DEMOCRATIC
MODERATES WHO WERE UPSET AFTER
THE 2020 ELECTION SAYING DON'T
YOU EVER AGAIN UNDER THE THREE
WORDS DEFUND THE POLICE, AND WAS
LESS MESSY.
NOW THEY ARE SAYING ABOUT
INFLATION.
THESE ARE DEMOCRATIC POLICY
PROMS, NOT JUST BIDEN PROBLEMS.
I WANT THEM ALL GONE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, I LOOK AT
THIS, JOE CONCHA, AND NOW WE ARE
SEEING THE MEDIA TWO AND A HALF
YEARS LATER AND ACKNOWLEDGE
OBVIOUS THAT WE HAD.
THIS TWO POINTS ABOUT THIS.
ONE, AND A DEMOCRAT MIGHT
REPLACE BIDEN'S PROBABLY GOING
TO ADOPT THE SAME POLICIES AND
SIMILARLY THE HOLDEN TO THE
CLIMATE ALARMIST CALLED THAT IS
THE DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST PARTY.
SO THINGS WON'T CHANGE IN THAT
RESPECT.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE -- I
MEAN, TO BE HONEST, THEY ALL
KNOW HOW BAD HIS CONDITION IS
AND IT'S PROBABLY WORSE THAN WE
EVEN CAN SEE.
YOU KNOW, DO WE NOT GET TO THE
POINT WHERE IT'S BORDERLINE
ELDER ABUSE WITH THIS GUY,
FORCING HIM OUT THERE AND
STUMBLING, STAMMERING, YOU KNOW,
TRIPPING AND FALLING AND THE
WIND BLEW HIM OVER, AT SOME
POINT, DOES ANYBODY CARE ABOUT
HIM ENOUGH TO SAY JOE, I THINK
IT'S TIME YOU NEED TO HAND THE
REINS OFF TO KAMALA OR SOMEBODY
ELSE?
>> ONE WOULD HOPE SO, SEAN.
BUT I THINK WHEN WE FOCUS ON
AGE, THE PREMISE SEEMS TO BE
THAT WHEN JOE BIDEN HAD HIS
FASTBALL, HE HAD THE PROPER
INSTINCTS AND HAVE THE PROPER
PERSPECTIVE AND POLICIES TO MOVE
THE COUNTRY FORWARD.
AND YOU ASK ROBERT GATES FOR
EXAMPLE, WHO WAS HIS DEFENSE
SECRETARY UNDER OBAMA AND BIDEN,
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID IN HIS BOOK
IN 2014, THAT HE WAS WRONG ABOUT
EVERY FOREIGN POLICY DECISION
THROUGHOUT HIS 50 YEAR CAREER,
WHETHER IT BE IN THE SENATE OR
AS VICE PRESIDENT.
REMEMBER, THIS IS THE GUY WHO
TOLD BARACK OBAMA HE SHOULD NOT
GO INTO PAKISTAN AND GET OSAMA
BIN LADEN.
THIS IS THE GUY WHO VOTED
AGAINST THE FIRST GULF WAR THAT
EVEN AL GORE HAD SUPPORTED AT
THAT POINT.
HIS INSTANCE ON FOREIGN POLICY
HAVE BEEN HORRIBLE, AND WHEN HIS
INSTINCT NOW, OR AT LEAST THE
INSTINCT OF HIS HANDLERS IS
LET'S SPEND TRILLIONS MORE SO WE
CAN LOWER INFLATION, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S NOT THE WAY IT WORKS, BUT
THEN TO THE AGE THING, WHEN HE
GETS UP IN FRONT OF THE PRESS ON
AN INTERNATIONAL STAGE AND AGAIN
DOES THAT WHOLE "THEY GAVE ME A
LIST OF REPORTERS TO CALL IN
THING," HE IS DONE IT MULTIPLE
TIMES AS PRESIDENT, AT SEVERAL
FLAVORS OF STUPID IN THE FLICK
THE PORCH LIGHT IS ON AND NO ONE
IS HOME.
YOU WOULD THINK SOMEONE SANE AND
SOBER THE WHITE HOUSE WOULD PULL
HIM ASIDE AND SAY PLEASE STOP
SHARING THAT INFORMATION BECAUSE
IT MAY LOOK LIKE YOU ARE
AVOIDING HARD QUESTIONS AND
CALLING ON THOSE WHO ONLY ASK
THE COTTON CANDY VARIETY.
AND OBAMA WON REELECTION BUT NOT
BECAUSE HIS POLICIES AND
PERFORMANCE WERE ALL THAT GREAT,
RIGHT?
BUT BECAUSE HE COULD PUT
TOGETHER A GOOD SPEECH AND GET
COHERENT ANSWERS.
UNLIKE HIS FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
IS NOW DOING AS PRESIDENT, BUT
ONE MORE POINT.
KELLYANNE IS EXACT THE RIGHT.
YOU CAN MAKE EVERY DEMOCRAT THAT
IS RUNNING IN THE CONGRESS AND
THE SENATE FOR A SEAT OR
ELECTION TO JOE BIDEN ON
INFLATION, ON EDUCATION, ON GAS
PRICES AND ON CRIME AND IF YOU
DO THAT AND YOU FOCUS ON THOSE
FOUR ISSUES LIKE A LASER, I
DON'T SEE HOW TOO MANY OF THEM
WILL LOSE, BECAUSE DEMOCRATS
DON'T HAVE A BUMPER STICKER, AND
THEY KNOW IT, SEAN.
>> Sean: QUICK EXIT QUESTION
AND PREDICTION FOR BOTH OF YOU.
KELLYANNE, WILL JOE BIDEN FINISH
HIS FIRST TERM?
>> YES.
HE'S NOT GOING TO FINISH ANY
SENTENCES, BUT HE WILL FINISH
HIS FIRST TERM.
>> Sean: THAT'S TOO FUNNY.
I CAN'T NOT LAUGH.
JOE CONCHA.
>> IT'S LIKE TRYING TO TAKE THE
KEYS FROM YOUR GRANDFATHER WHO
IS 84 AND SHOULDN'T BE DRIVING
ANYMORE.
HE'S NOT LETTING GO OF THOSE
KEYS.
JOE BIDEN IS NOT LETTING GO OF
HIS PRESIDENCY.
>> Sean: IF IT WAS MY FATHER
OR MOTHER, I WOULD TAKE THE KEYS
AND I'D FIND A WAY AND I WOULD
HIRE A DRIVER, GET HIM AN